[Music]
for me the most important thing is the
story that I'm telling whether it's a
scary set piece or a dramatic moment it
all comes down to the characters and if
you care about them Aquaman is very
powerful but what drives him comes from
a very human place historic resonated
with me instantly
it's not accepted here not really
accepted here definitely can identify
with that
I fell in love with the project and love
with Mira she's no damsel in distress
she's miss strong badass empowered
superhero with Aquaman a trick and also
put up a fun is designing a whole
different world that we've never seen
before you're pretty much is limited by
your own imagination it's just a whole
lot of magic on this project once they
put all these things together behind
James his vision blows my mind still
the appeal of it was to step into
something else
you really are invigorated because a
very good experience all these amazing
worlds we haven't been under the ocean
yet this is our outer space I keep going
back to that inherent fascination that
we have with the ocean and if it turned
on you just the sheer Asness and the
mystery of it there's still a lot we
don't know I've always known that I want
to do it acts of moving I'll get to be a
big kid on the playground and cause
trouble blow things up your body is
constantly working we go judo jujitsu
fight choreography a four and a half
months stunt training six days a week
you feel pretty superhuman I get two
presents Aquaman to the wall in this
really badass and cool way we have never
seen this on screen and that's that's
the truth get a fall in love with the
idea what it's like to have these powers
and be a kid and that's one fan fan it's
fun for everyone
we want to create something interesting
you don't want the standard gyms one
can't do the standard
any great superhero story should make
you feel that you've learned something
from these characters and you yourself
have the ability to do good and you
don't need a cape to be able to do that
you
[Music]
you